حرب لاتهدا في خير صوت المدفعيه
الاوكرانيه حاضره هنا على الدواء ندخل الى
احدى نقاط الاشتباك السريه للجيش
الاوكراني يقول الاوكرانيون ان جبهه
الجنوب تميل لصالحهم نقف الان عند اقرب
خطوط المواجهه بين القوات الاوكرانيه
والروسيه هذه واحده من الدبابات
الاوكرانيه التي سمح لنا بتصويرها وهي
تتهيا في هذه اللحظه للاطلاق باتجاه
القوات الروسيه
غير بعيد يستعد جنود مدفعيه لاطلاق قذائف
جديده تتوارى المدافع الاوكرانيه خلف
اغصان الاشجار تحسبا من عدو غير مرئي
قائد الفريق يتاكدوا من كل خطوه فعلى
الجبهه لا مجالا للخطا
هناك على الضفه المقابله في هذه اللحظه
يتم ارسال موقعهم الينا بدقه عبر اللاسلكي
وانتظار الامر باستهدافهم
حانت لحظه الاطلاق
[تصفيق]
قديفه اخرى يهتز مكانه من قوتها
يقول الجيش الاوكراني ان هذه الصور تظهر
قصفه نقاط الروسيه في مكان اخر ترابط
مدفعيه هوتزر الامريكيه في اطار الدعم
العسكري الذي تقدمه واشنطن لكيف
ورنيه
بقصف المدينه والمواقع السكنيه والبنيه
التحتيه
تتوسع دائره الحرب فالقصف الروسي على مركز
المدينه لا يتوقف عشرات الالاف فروا وبقي
اخرون اما احلامهم بان تضع الحرب اوزارها
قريبا فذهبت ادراج الريح
سيطر الروس على مقاطعه خرسون في بدايه
الحرب قبل ان يستعيد الاوكرانيون مدينتها
اواخر العام الماضي لينسحب الروس الى
الضفه الشرقيه من نهر النيبر التي تشكل
قرابه نصف المقاطعه ولخير سون اهميتها
بدءا من موقعها على البحر الاسود وبحر
ازوف وليس انتهاء بارتباطها بشبه جزيره
القرد